all right jordan bates what's up
not too much how's it going atlas thanks
for coming on the program
thank you bro good to be here hell yeah
what a divine synchronicity
that we got the
chance to come here together we're
currently
at bentino massaro's
shift into permanent alignment retreat
in costa rica
and we're super pumped for it
and we've both been profoundly
positively influenced by him
and we've also both come from a
somewhat similar exploratory
seeking process
that has landed us at this
always already free
we're free already
yeah nothing to do no one to be it's
just
this right here it's doing itself i
don't know how it's doing it i don't
know how i'm doing this but it's just
doing itself
and that's freedom this just does itself
yeah
effortlessly yes spontaneously
i've liked using a single
word to describe
source the ineffable as
i said yet the word that is most
fun for me to add a word
a characteristic or descriptor to source
is creativity
yeah how do you feel about that
yeah i think sources
destructive creativity in its aspect of
a form when you look at when you look at
form it's constantly
the forms are constantly shifting a new
world is being born every moment
an entire world is dying every moment
another world is being born every moment
so it's the oroboros it's the creative
destruction
and yet the fundamental substance here
the invisible universal substance that
is actually
apparently shifting into different forms
never departs from itself it never
changes it's always just this same
essence so in that sense actually
nothing is created and nothing is
destroyed there's just this motionless
freedom just just sitting here just
watching itself just
already whole already complete already
perfect just doing its thing
that's what i would say
yeah i've really appreciated the
sanskrit word lila the divine play
for it all i also really found it
interesting as i
made that visualization
that had the source light refracting
through
the diamond that little prism that
was described as the awareness that then
goes out into the creations forms names
ten thousand things
it was cool that you thought that that
was somewhat interesting enough to share
with some people
and that i
had even posted this other one that was
sort of around these
in a sense two attractors you have one
attractor which is that
source and then you have which is has
that
gps callback functionality of seeking
when people like in the parable of the
prodigal son
venture outward hit a breaking point
trying to find happiness in maya in the
illusion and the intoxication
and then they begin investigating their
awareness
so in a sense these little
visualizations and explanations of the
ineffable like you just described a
moment ago
has been really insightful for myself
as well as for other people sort of
comparing maps
around have i become the witness
am i at least not absorbed in the
thoughts
and in the clouds in the perceptions and
the objects
but am i at least aware of myself as the
sky
in which they happen that it's eternal
yeah it's been interesting hearing how
you feel about the maps
unpack a little bit about that for us
yeah so i think every map is useful as
far as it goes but
at a certain point you know you have to
kill the buddha you have to
burn every map you have to burn every
boat that got you
to that point to that particular island
on the way
at a certain point every map loses its
usefulness every word
loses its usefulness even words like
absolute
source consciousness awareness at a
certain point you have to say
there is no source there is no absolute
there is no witness
there is no awareness all of these are
just words
all these are just mouth noises what are
the words pointing at what is the
the moon what is that unspeakable world
that you just leap into when you drop
all concepts
and you just leap just jump ship
completely
just get out of the conceptual mind and
come
right to where you've always been except
stripped of concepts just back to infant
mind back to this primordial
primordial kaleidoscopic
hyperdimensional etheric
tapestry that's just dancing itself in a
completely unsayable
unpindownable way when you're in that
when you're just stranger in a strange
land
no location no reference points you know
that's when you're home that's when you
that's when you
remember what freedom is is what i would
say
yeah i was reading sri ramana maharshi
and srina sagar to maharaja recently and
they're both saying
very similar leverage the words
and the lexicon for you to better
understand the stages and where you're
at
and then drop the words as soon as
possible once you recognize it
drop the words as soon as possible and
just be that freedom
that you already are
and so then one of the things is that
the bodhisattva comes up so in a sense
you want to
undergo this tantric weaving of your
realizations because you recognize that
all these
other selves that are
suffering in this dream
that the absolute highest thing that you
can do
is to as ramana maharshi said sahaja
samadhi you want to
weave your enlightened realizations into
the social fabric and you do so
by being able to help people with this
lexicon because if
if uh if somebody
you know you can look out at the
fractals
right we have we have all of these
different
fractals in
the planet's secretions
and
when we look at a when we look at a
a bird that's chirping
it's not singing to an audience when we
look at a flower that's growing it's not
trying to grow
when we look at a caterpillar
it naturally becomes a butterfly
metamorphosis
and so we can in a sense use
these very simple explainers
in this whole already free free
already style pointing that then
gets the sort of contracted energy to
just release
to help people but yet the whole thing
with what the buddha taught
and what the four noble truths are about
and just a way to liberate yourself from
suffering in general and even the ten
commandments and confucius's analects
all of these projects around morality
as well is that
even in the idea of free yourself
you're free already there's still
this importance to
having a high amount of morality or
having a
mastery over your thought stream if your
thought stream is still
running you around like the monkey mind
and you're still egoic and reacting
rather than creating the pause and all
of that stuff then
what good does it do for you to know
that you're free
because you're still a slave to
reacting to external stimuli
yeah i would say it depends um if if a
person truly deeply notices that
freedom is freedom is the case all
thoughts are made out of freedom
all thoughts are entirely made out of
the absolute made out of the absolute
radiance that is just totally at home
with itself
then it really doesn't matter what
thoughts are appearing because
you just see that they're not even
thoughts actually the word thought is
even an abstraction
and a conceptual overlay atop what is
happening what is happening is just
radiance dancing in different modalities
you can break it up into modalities
there aren't actually separate
modalities we can say there's
the feel the visual field the thought
field the sound field
you know the field of of touch and taste
these are all
actually just aspects on the same
continuum and none of it can actually be
said what it is it's all just the same
continuum
and it's all the same absolute radiance
absolute at-homeness and so if you see
that thoughts are made out of that
then you see through thought and it
doesn't really matter which thoughts
arise
and it's hard to imagine that you would
still really be able to get hooked by
too many thoughts if you really see
through thoughts to that level
i mean good point still though the
character
is gonna have some momentum just the
conditioning of your particular karma
your particular environment and
upbringing has a certain momentum
um maybe your past lives if you if you
subscribe to that sort of
understanding have a certain momentum
and sometimes awakening
just blows out like 95 percent of your
conditioning and momentum and sometimes
it blows out 10 to 15 percent
and you have to spend a lot more and
then you spend a lot more time
gradually dissolving the person with all
the person's particular idiosyncrasies
but there's nothing wrong with the
idiosyncrasies it's actually fun to just
not no longer feel like guilt and shame
about your
character's particular foibles and
idiosyncrasies but instead you just kind
of
gently and humorously and humbly just
observe your character
behaving how your character is behaving
you know maybe you
maybe you're having a beer maybe you're
watching porn and jerking off but you
you're maybe you're still awake during
that process and you're just seeing this
is just what's
happening right now you know awakening
is not about
changing your behavior in a particular
way it's about relaxing into what
already is this freedom that is already
here regardless of what
may or may not be happening it just is
the case freedom is
and absolutely there's a lot to be said
for
for alignment and for the bodhisattva
path if that type of thing resonates
with you
but even more fundamentally than that
you know most fundamentally is like wake
up and realize the freedom that you are
whatever you if you feel like trying to
be a bodhisattva and
give people red pills after that then
that's great that sounds like an amazing
way
to spend your time if you feel like you
know pulling a ryokan
the whatever 15th century zen poet and
just going and being a hermit and like
living in your own little shack and
writing poetry for the rest of your life
then go do that
um because ultimately freedom is all
beings are
are already free um so you know it's
kind of whatever game your soul wants to
play
just realize what this is realize what
you are realize
you're already free and it's already
perfect and then just play the game you
want to play dance the dance you want to
dance
and just enjoy the hell out of it
because that's what that's what we're
here to do
just dance and play and enjoy that's
what i would say
hi
i love that in a sense there's
a already always
freedom that is the undercurrent of the
eternity that this is the infinity that
this
is and yet also at the same time
there's a perfecting that happens within
its
creativity so here we are in this
evolutionary ascent and although it's
dreamed
we evolve from a place of more limbic
more primal where maya is intoxicating
us the illusion
is intoxicating us we're reactive
we're barely aware of our own true
nature and awareness
and especially that it's impersonal
that it's all one god self and then over
time what happens
in this multi thousand year long
ascent and beyond we
perfect ourselves away from maya
away from the intoxication away from the
illusion away from the primal
limbic ego driven behaviors and towards
enlightened awakened highest morality
bodhisattva
style behaviors so to me there's a
simultaneity that happens with the
underlying
undercurrent that is always already
absolutely free
and yet simultaneously recognizing that
the reason why i became so free
was because i did the hard work
that enabled me to not be reactive
to have dissolved my ego to have made it
so that
i'm only in service to the absolute
highest
weaving awakening into the fabric
so you're right in many ways and it's
just that there's always this like
component to it that there's a
preference
still for clean water instead of dirty
water
and that's the sort of thing that i'm
talking about is there's a preference
for enlightenment
there's a preference for awakening a
preference for
no ego a preference for the dissolving
of
all self-dealing and
the preference for
the maximizing abundance prosperity love
light wisdom harmony
period meeting basic needs actualizing
gifts all of that kind of stuff
beautifully said beautifully said yeah i
would say what comes up for me in
relation to that
is that i would say that i'm not right i
would say fundamentally i'm trying to
lie in the most accurate way possible
right now because no words we can say
can even come close to what this actual
this right here this now
what is this i can't say it i can't say
it none of these words can say it i can
only
point at it and then you can burn me
down kill the buddha and just notice it
for yourself what is going on here
i would say the story you're telling the
story of
you know forgetting and remembering and
going through these deep
contractions and then these these deep
expansions and back into remembrance
deeply resonates like i i would say
that let's call it a mythology is
one of the mythologies that resonates
most deeply with me
and that i feel is most generative most
useful
at this point in human history at this
stage of the zeitgeist i can't think of
a much more beautiful
mythology to put forth of what's
happening like we're
being summoned back into a golden age or
summoned toward
a collective awakening and there's this
gorgeous opportunity we have to remember
what we are
and to redesign the dna of civilization
based on these
awakened understandings of what's
happening here i do still feel though
that that
again is ultimately just another story
and i don't
actually fundamentally know i don't even
know
if we're evolving or devolving i
i don't know i don't know what this is i
don't know what's happening here i don't
know what humanity is i don't know what
the world is i don't know what beings
are i don't know what any of that stuff
is it's all it's all mysterious
already awake already free god nectar
just existing
as it is and we in every story we can
tell any beautiful story we want
and every story is true within its own
context every reality
tunnel is true within its own context
it's true as far as it goes
but from the absolute lens every story
is a very involves a very heavy-handed
cherry-picking process where we're
cherry-picking different
data points and using confirmation bias
to say yes i see this data point this
pattern this data point this pattern and
we're
we're giving ourselves this feedback
loop that reinforces our particular
narrative
and everyone is involved in this all the
time but the the truth is that the
number of data points we're cherry
picking is just vastly vastly smaller
than the amount of information that's
actually happening here because even in
this moment
where i'm apparently talking to you
there are infinite bits of information
happening here i could dial in on this
tiny shade of brown
over here and say what's going on with
that shade of brown that doesn't seem to
have anything to do with
the cosmos like forgetting what it is
and then remembering and going through
this crazy evolution process
it just seems to be a little speck of
radiance doing its thing
and it's really only our linear
storytelling narrativizing minds that
give this impression of a linear
narrative that does
x or y and ultimately there's just this
there's just this self-awake radiance
just right here now just
already free already fully at home with
itself
and it's like the only thing blocking
you from noticing that is just the
clouds in front of the sun
the the sun is already here the clouds
don't really exist but they're created
by
your identification with thought you're
believing that your thoughts are
actually saying something real about
reality
creates the clouds in front of the sun
when you stop believing your thoughts
and just drop concepts and just return
to pure infant mind all that's here
is just this completely unsayable
kaleidoscopic already at home
awakeness and that is the absolute that
is god you are god it's right here it's
right now it's not a secret it's
it's that's the cosmic joke it's the
only thing you've ever seen this is
right in front of you
right now um [ __ ] yeah
yeah i love it
your focus on
pointing to
when rumi says that we go from room to
room looking for the diamond necklace
that's already around our neck
typically the first things that
come to mind in that pointing are to say
that
we're looking for happiness in
what is not awareness we're we're
looking for happiness in maya we're
looking for happiness in the
intoxicative illusion
seeking peace and happiness that i will
extract it from objects and experiences
and substances and relationships and all
that stuff
and so typically if we're in that
process especially we're
associating ourselves with our thoughts
with our perceptions with our layers of
identity
i like how jordan's been using this
kaleidoscopic is a really good way to
explain it because it's very similar to
the mandelbrot
fractal as well the fractaling that
happens
and so the kaleidoscopic
nest to it is why he gets these
layers of identity and i get these
layers
of identity but we become enslaved
to form ego enslaves us to form
and so we in a sense shed like an onion
those layers of identity
off off i'm i'm not my body i'm not my
ethnicity i'm not my career i'm not
my thoughts perceptions objects
experiences subsystems not any of those
things i'm just the pure bear empty
awareness that
very awakeness
right there together that's impersonal
that's impersonal that we share
that is eternal and that the
appearances of form are endless they
will never
stop this is what is most transient what
is most transient
is these appearances of form creativity
and yet what's permanent what stays the
same
forever is the very
shared eternal agent of awareness
itself that is always going to be
witnessing
the movies that are playing
you are the white source light
abide as that abide as that which makes
the witnessing
possible abide as that which makes
perception
possible abide as that which watches
the endless beautiful
appearances
that beautiful yeah the clear light just
happiness is so it's a paradox for
happiness to go looking for happiness
somewhere else when happiness is it's
what you are so
why would happiness reach over here for
how happiness come to me but i'm
entirely made of happiness it's just
what i am i'm just made of happiness
i'm made of that clear light i'm made of
that
that awakeness and yeah that which
enables awakeness that
zero space of infinite possibility it's
just yes this moment now
yeah yeah one of the big things that
i'm noticing about this already
always free being our true nature
and that the
sort of headless centerless
hurricane like process
non-dual
is that it's both
perfect and it's perfecting
happiness is already here
period like you said it is our true
nature
yet like in the sufi
metaphysics only the ignorant seek
what's already there
yet it remains for you to recognize it
so it's like the perfection perfecting
and just like in the happiness one as
well
there are still a billion people that
don't have access to clean water
and if you're truly an impersonal
witness
you know that you are that which
experiences
through a billion people the lack of the
basic need not being met
and that's the sort of perfecting that
happens at the same time which is that
we
recognize that via that impersonal
witnessing
and as that basic need gets met we
entrepreneurially
maximize the social fabrics potential
those basic needs get met and then those
billion people get to
flower their unique contribution their
unique
gift in this appearance
and so that's it's been a core to sort
of be able to
simultaneously hold perfection and
perfecting
because i remember five years ago
it doesn't even matter if somebody told
me that i'm always already free
i would have no [ __ ] idea what
they're talking about
period so in a sense it took five years
of sort of studying the mystic
traditions attending meditation retreats
quieting the mind down becoming the
witness making that impersonal
recognizing that this is all already
free
and so that's the sort of perfecting
that happens with the already perfect
how do you feel
[Music]
yeah beautifully said beautifully said
and yeah eventually when you do remember
that it it is this always already free
and awake perfection
you realize it was that the whole time
even while it was
even while it was perfecting and
remembering and when it was apparently
not
remembering even when it was apparently
not remembering it was still
remembering at the same time it was
still perfect it was still awake
yeah that whole time and what may have
seemed like
you know long decades of human suffering
are eventually seen to have just been
like as a spark in a bonfire like just a
micro drop in an oceanic eternity
that just knows no suffering at all that
knows no suffering at all
and yeah it's tricky how we dance
between these perspectives of
you know the apparent absolute versus
the apparent relative
in actuality there is no there is no
distinction the absolute is relative the
relative is absolute
and yet at the same time yeah i also
deeply resonate as a
as a
a heart opened human being at that
perspective i totally resonate with the
view
of yeah we have an amazing opportunity
at this juncture in history to
liberate mankind's apparent situation to
a degree
never before experienced in recorded
history on this planet there's a
possibility for
universal abundance raising the
universal baseline of prosperity to
never before
seen levels and just see
okay we sorry we got a phone call let's
see if we get the
we got the counter going okay we're
counting back on all right
okay okay yeah so i resonate with the
perspective that we have a
totally un unprecedented opportunity
right now
from the relative perspective as
apparent human beings in this apparent
realm
this is a playground we can play like to
the max we can generate
never before seen levels of abundance
and prosperity creativity we have the
technology
we have the imagination we're capable of
so much more than what within what we're
currently doing and it's it's a
beautiful game to
you know play this game in this earth
realm and see
what kind of gorgeous possibilities we
can we can
actualize and that game is especially
fun when you know
that you're already home yes and that
you're already free and then it's all a
game
and then at the end of the show this
theater play
we're all gonna take off the mass and
we're all gonna have a beer and a joint
and we're all gonna laugh and remember
that it was all a dream and it was all
for fun
and that what we really are is
completely untouched by all this
it is just that already awake radiance
that is just here now this completely
inexplicable suchness
that is just that dimension of presence
the direct felt presence of experiencing
here now
that is what you are and the more you
know that and come from that
and embody as that that in itself has
the biggest
impact on this apparent human game that
we're playing as well yes the more you
know that the more you embody that the
more you
exist at that level of beingness your
beingness is the most fundamental thing
all your actions all your actions are
permeated by your level of beingness the
energy you're operating from
the energy you're coming from so where
you're coming from is most fundamental
what you do is secondary so the biggest
gift that you can give to the world
is just to remember what you are yes and
then from there
just joyfully share your gifts playfully
share your gifts do the thing that
lights you up do what ignites you do
what electrifies you do what excites you
because that's when you truly like
radiate at the next level that's when
you're just you just become a beacon and
you're like oh my [ __ ] god i love
life this is insane look at what the
[ __ ] is going on here we're in this
insanely futuristic techno wonderland
narnia we have insane possibilities
i can just rap and sing and dance and
laugh and play
and you know that's when you really
inspire people on the next level to
remember
that we are joyful creators what we are
as joyful creators
some of us have forgotten that and we're
and are identifying as victims and as
small separate beings but we are
the one joyful creator we are the one
blissful creator
of all of this and creator and creation
are not separate this is this is the
creator this is the creation
this is the body of god you are it and
you can do whatever you like
just have fun it's it's fun it's all for
fun
beautiful thank you brother you
nice to meet you today i know wow we had
so many funny
non-dual jokes in the car and
we've just been kicking it today it's
been great
i didn't even know that yeah you built
with jordan leduwon
your business and yeah and he's
been a big influence on a lot of the
ways that i think as well and so
yeah jordan lege1 founded
hiexistence.com
and i became a co-owner of high
existence co-creator some years ago
and worked on that for a while and now
been doing my my own thing for like the
last year or so
i also had my own blog that whole time
refinedthemind.com and then
yeah more recently i'm creating
something called auroboros
so that's what i'm up to uh in
in the 3d yeah and you're hosting
in mexico after this two retreats
so there's some plant medicines and some
non-dual
teachings yeah having an ayahuasca and
bufo
and direct non-dual inquiry retreat with
also dance and music and rap and fun in
mexico
in april and then having a similar
retreat with with yahay which is a close
cousin of ayahuasca
basically ayahuasca in the sequoia
tradition having that in costa rica in
june so
um where can people find that um so if
you follow me
on instagram or twitter at um at
underscore
jordan underscore baits or if you go to
yeah from there you can just find my
link tree subscribe to my newsletter if
you like
or go to refinedthemind.com you can also
find my newsletter um that's probably
the best way to go at this point
we'll put the links in the bio below
and then
in the macro level picture what i really
like about this
one infinite creator eternally
expressing itself
i really like how as you described that
there's this you know ramdas talks about
it a lot as well
is that and eckhart tolle does as well
is that you basically have to die
before you die and that's your ego death
and then you become that one god self
and then ron bells also talks about it
like when you do die
it's like taking off a really tight shoe
and so in a sense it's like stripping
off of this costume
in its fullest but then what's really
interesting is that
as is talked about in the traditions if
you've really achieved
nirvana regardless if you have
ended your cycle of births and deaths
in this creation as is taught about in
the law of one by raw is that
you end up regardless serving as your
higher self to all of these
other in this multiverse all of these
other little
jordan bates characters that are at all
of the other lower densities and you
just serve that
for a long long long time and that
then then after
you played as the jordan bates character
as is talked about in the love one it's
like the whole creation uses
all of what's learned and explored as
its passport
into the next creation the next
exploration you get to put on some sort
of other
costume and identity and layers all of
us do
and that's the soul and that's the
playfulness the end the endless
child-like laughter of the infinite as
orobindo says
and so in a sense the perfecting process
in each one of these creations is you
you slowly
find the well of honey that's under the
rock
you are already the well of honey you're
already that
this is already free and yet there's a
little egoic
contracted rock that needs to be you
know really looked at if you look
at the seer at consciousness long enough
that you'll dissolve that rock you'll
recognize that your true nature
is what is eternal and shared here that
is endlessly
exploring all possibilities of
transience
fractaling kaleidoscoping as you said
and so that's just been really important
is to know how to jedi
navigate across that
because i think it's a little bit too
easy
sometimes to just
give only one layer of exploration of
what
explanation of what it is the one layer
of exploration is
you're already perfect it's already it
we're already free done end of story
just be exactly what is happening
that and yet the other layer within that
that is typically brushed off and this
is why the tijit2
has the monist which we just talked
about and then it has the yin yang the
duelist within it
in one symbol because then that's the
perfecting
it's awareness forgetting that
its nature is that and that it gets
intoxicated by maya
and it undergoes that process of
suffering being the drill sergeant for
it to go and investigate its true nature
again like you said it's all story
like you said it's all story but it's
the closest stories we can get to
explaining the ineffable in a way that
helps the ascent of other people to
this recognition
and that's the point of sort of refining
the
maps and refining your jedi-like ability
for each of us
yeah beautifully said again and um
yeah i would say you know that resonates
that the additional
mythological elaborations there about
what
all this is where it's going through
these different densities these
different
creation bubbles reaching completion and
then morphing to the next
stage all that sounds super epic i
really like the
the heuristic that um like
whatever the most epic story you can
tell is that's probably how it is
because god seems to love
epic stories um that's a good one but
but at the same yeah at the same time
though i also just yeah i have to say
again that i just
um i don't know i don't know
but i don't know about those stories i
don't know the truth of that
you know it's like the
the trap of the stories is that you can
get your mind can really
grab on to the stories you can get
really lost in all these mythologies and
you can think
you know you can weave the super
elaborate
very serious seeming web of like cosmic
evolution
process and and and it can just become
another another dogma another ideology
another
ism and so you know
hold those lightly those are fun to play
with great point great but
also just continually burn them down
continually burn them down continually
say
what is the law of one who is ra that's
nobody that's nobody
kill the buddha kill raw kill the law of
one
you know kill the kill non-duality kill
duality
kill perfection kill already free
kill suffering kill the ego yeah yeah
yeah kill jordan bates kill the
absolutely kill the app kill adams
kill the atlas character yeah yeah yeah
interesting
yeah exactly yeah that's the true
surrendered process
too as you've been using it's sort of to
the bonfire
burn burn surrender surrender
devotional surrender yeah give it all
back to god yeah
just give it all back to god but yeah i
do i've seen
on ayahuasca you know visions of like
this upward spiraling process
across you know infinite omniverses
where all the diamonds are being
perfected
i love that that's my [ __ ] fave
i love that one oh
that's my fave oh i'm so glad you
brought that one up
yeah yeah that like i mean i've seen
that and it looked [ __ ]
astounding and i've seen how also every
diamond the whole time it's like indra's
net and every single diamond on this
upward spiraling path
is the microcosm perfectly reflecting
the macrocosm and every diamond is
constantly the perfect diamond buddha
reflecting all the other mirrors in the
exact perfect way
every mirror giving every other mirror
exactly what it needs
in all moments at all times even hitler
and trump
giving everyone the perfect mirror that
they needed at that time not a single
thread out of place
and i love that story and yet i also
have to burn
that down and just and just say that's
also a story it's [ __ ] beautiful
story you know we're here to tell
beautiful
stories and live in them and enjoy them
and play play in them
but just remember that their stories and
just keep burning them down and come
back to
living mystery living unspeakable
mystery completely unsavable
is-ness here now emptiness dancing don't
know what it is
non-conceptual totality non-conceptual
totality of what is
that is what is here that's all that you
can actually
that's all that's actually here
non-conceptual openness you can't find
anything else
other than that you can't find
non-conceptual openness either it's all
you can't find any particular thing look
go look for the upward spiraling
path of perfect diamond perfection you
won't find it you can't find any
particular thing
particular things are the domain of
concepts in the mind
so if you want to find what's really
here you have to go through that portal
of unfindability
to the no particular thingness yeah you
have to shut the [ __ ] up
and and and look at the
the dot dot dot the no particular thing
this the blankness the
the blank slate go back to the blank
slate wipe the cpu clean
the silence between the notes
the blank canvas that gets colored
the infinite amount of ways that you can
modulate a screen
to make movies the endless amount of
ways that you can vibrate your vocal
cords
to make languages the endless amount of
ways that you can combine
food to make recipes
the yeah go ahead
and as well just want to say that these
are also totally
notes to self because still i notice my
mind all the time like going down these
rabbit holes and
wondering about these elaborate stories
of like hmm
is the absolute like you know beyond
awareness and stuff like this these very
like subtle points of non-duality my
mind still totally like
t like chews on that stuff and like
spins in circles
and then i keep coming back to yeah but
i
gotta burn all that down that's all
that's all [ __ ]
absolute awareness every word is
pointing at the exact same thing every
the actual
the actual thing that every word is
pointing at is just
this unspeakable is-ness now every word
has the same meaning ultimately it's
only will be this unspeakable
is-ness endlessly
boom boom [ __ ] yeah
beautiful bro it's a good note so good
dude
yeah of course i'm feeling it i was so
feeling that i like that electricity for
that
wrapping and maybe wrap yeah oh yeah oh
and rapping actual rapping all right
let's let's let's go
post a [ __ ] wreath here at ben
retreat though okay bro whatever though
non-dual flow to oneness is so fun kid
you could just play and just let it
[ __ ] jump and jack itself kangaroo
hyperflow up to the next echelon the
diamond spiraling process the indra's
net
you know just let that go ahead and let
that do
what they want to do on ios now i'm
seeing visions the magic is real and i
see it i live it when i get to go and
the haters be tripping and cory bmj and
i scotty pippen and when i said purging
i really be tripping we trusted divine
so we never be slipping i'm feeling like
nice man [ __ ] it was written we two kids
from iowa you know we be gifted we smoke
em a pot
of chunks tobacco we're clearing the
space so i burned palo santo my medicine
combo and you know i got you all i tell
all my haters no more arigato
[Applause]
wow holy wow you went
speed yeah that last part i gotta say
was a written verse the first part was
pure freestyle then i jumped into a song
that i had written before i was just
like i felt like dropping that verse so
yeah wow
uh can you drop something slow
for me yeah yeah i like i like slow you
were so fast i have to re-listen to it
okay draw me some slow yeah yeah
yeah awareness baby
look at your awareness look at the seer
feel how near it's dear
right there in your heart right there in
the center
all is perfect let it go
let every single thought go
let every single cloud go
you are the eternal sky yes you no you
have just forgotten about it
don't forget it though remember it
remember it
yo that is exactly what you are
moment to moment your status peace and
happiness
bliss non-dual whirlwind
you are not even here it's only freedom
you are not even here it's only freedom
you are not even here
it's own leaf absolute
freedom
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
so good to meet you brother
amazing wow high vibes to start this
high fives to start the retreat damn
yeah that was so solid
wow wow okay here we go boom
all right check out the links in the bio
below to jordan's profiles
as well as all the places you can join
them on retreats
check out all those links below let us
know your thoughts about the episode we
would love to hear from you
in the comments below if the video
brought you value give it a like
subscribe if you haven't share the video
with other people
you feel like it could bring value to we
adore you
infinitely already
[Music]
free